- Okay, good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to the session.
This is NET 403, Hybrid
Connectivity at Scale,
a Deep Dive into Direct Connect.
So thank you all for
coming to the session.
I wanted to start out with
a very simple question
to all of you, which
is what was on my mind
when I joined AWS a number of years ago,
when someone said, "Hey, can
you talk to some customers
"about Direct Connect?"
And my thought was, "How hard can it be?"
It's just VLANs, we just
need to know a little bit
about 802.1Q, bit of
trunking, that sort of thing.
Little bit of BGP, need
to know about AS numbers,
that sort of thing, configuring filters
and prefix lists on routers.
Of course, the AWS side of things,
we need to configure
things in the console,
and of course, the piece of equipment,
the router on the other end of it.
So how hard could it really be?
Now, something I wanted
to get out of the way.
My name is Steve Seymour.
I'm the worldwide tech lead for networking
and solutions architecture at AWS.
I spoke about Direct Connect back in 2016,
and one of the things that I
just wanted to remind people of
was, as you can probably
tell from my accent,
I'm from the UK, we say roots,
and I did explain that back then.
It didn't quite sink in, so
I had to go the next year,
tried again to explain
what a router really is,
and this year, I've kind of given up,
so I asked someone else to join me.
- So I'm Josh Dean, I'm a product manager
on the Direct Connect team.
I was also born in the
UK, so I was a router guy,
but now I'm a router
guy, so I'm a convert.
- So hopefully between us,
we've got people covered,
whichever one you prefer.
So another question,
who's used Direct Connect?
Okay, a fair few of you.
There's one or two that
didn't put their hands up,
but I wanted to maybe give
you a bit of history here,
because at re:Invent back in 2014,
we actually used Direct
Connect here at the conference.
We used it for a couple of demos,
a couple of launches
that we did that year,
and if you came to re:Invent
the following year,
and came in 2015, it
was actually being used
to deliver most of the event network.
So if you went to anything on AWS in 2015,
you would have been using Direct Connect,
and perhaps unsurprisingly, this year,
Direct Connect is a key part
of the network infrastructure
that we deploy here for re:Invent,
and it's been that way for
the last couple of years.
So actually, if you've used
the Wi-Fi here at re:Invent,
and accessed anything
at all that is on AWS,
you have used Direct Connect.
So perhaps that's
everyone now in the room?
Okay, so let's get started,
and obviously, when I
say how hard can it be,
there is quite a bit
more to Direct Connect,
and we're gonna walk you
through in this session
everything from physical infrastructure,
so looking at Direct Connect locations,
looking at the different
interfaces that we have,
how to organize cross-connects,
where partners fit into things.
We're gonna look at the
logical infrastructure,
the various types of virtual interfaces,
and of course, we can't avoid BGP,
it's gonna be part of this session.
And then the other end of this,
the cloud infrastructure, the
AWS side of it, of course.
So that's the plan for this session.
So what is Direct Connect?
Well, it is a physical connection
between your infrastructure
and the AWS infrastructure.
And I say physical connection
because it does involve cross-connects,
connecting pieces of
fiber between equipment
to enable traffic to flow
from your infrastructure
into the AWS backbone
and into our regions.
Originally, it supported
a couple of connections,
perhaps in a location to
one region, perhaps one VPC,
but Direct Connect has
evolved a lot over the years
that I've been talking about it.
So Direct Connect now
supports connectivity
to multiple regions using
Direct Connect gateway,
and of course, multiple VPCs as a result.
And it also supports now
connecting into things
like Cloud WAN, transit
gateways, et cetera.
So Direct Connect has evolved over time,
as you would expect.
But we're gonna go right
back to the beginning
in terms of establishing
these connections.
So that physical connectivity.
When you're establishing your first
Direct Connect with AWS,
one of the first
decisions you need to make
is where are you going to do it?
So as I like to say,
it's a location, location,
location discussion.
You need to go look on our website
and look at the different locations
that we have around the
world for Direct Connect.
These are locations where
we have infrastructure
and we can provide ports
for you to connect to.
When you look at that
table on our website,
we list out the locations,
we list out what is called
the associated region,
and the set of features available
at that particular location.
So if you wanted a particular
amount of bandwidth,
you can look down that
table and recognize,
hey, this particular location,
it supports the bandwidth that I need.
And we support one gig, 10 gig,
100 gig, and 400 gig ports.
Not all locations have all of
those different bandwidths,
so check the list for which
one makes sense for you.
You're also gonna be
making a decision there
based on where your infrastructure is.
And it might be that you have
your network infrastructure
already in one of those locations,
which makes the choice really quite easy.
If, however, you're connecting
to some on-premises infrastructure
or another data center,
then you'd be choosing the
Direct Connect locations
that are closer physically
to that data center,
because you're gonna have
to order the connectivity
from our Direct Connect
location to your infrastructure.
Now, creating a connection
is really quite simple.
Give it a name, choose the
location from that list.
There is an option at the bottom there
which says you would like
a MACSEC-enabled port.
And I'm gonna talk about that
a little bit more later on,
but that's also listed in that table,
which locations support MACSEC.
So if you plan to use MACSEC,
this is the time you make that decision.
It's not something you change later on.
If you would like a port
that is capable of MACSEC,
so encryption, choose it when you order
the connection at the beginning.
You're gonna notice
throughout the slides here
that we have these boxes
down in the bottom corner.
These are just to call
out some of the quotas
that we have around Direct Connect.
Many of these you can just
request an increase for.
But in this example, it's 10 connections
per location per region.
That's your starting point
for ordering Direct Connect connections.
Okay, so we've ordered our connection.
We've clicked through on the console.
Well, the next step, surely,
we just need to get ourselves connected.
We just plug in, don't we?
Well, the photo that I'm showing you here,
this is an example of a meet-me room.
So this is Equinix TY2.
And as you can see, it's
full of a lot of fiber,
a lot of ports.
This is actually a very,
very tidy, neat meet-me room.
And this is where your port from AWS
is presented for you to consume.
So when you order that connection,
we then issue something called an LOA CFA.
So an LOA is a letter of authorization.
It is your permission to
plug into a particular port.
And CFA is the Connecting
Facility Assignment.
It's basically where is that port.
So this document contains
everything you need
to be able to plug into that
Direct Connect port on our side.
It's gonna contain other information,
such as the connector type.
So LC connector is
typically what we would see.
It's a single-mode connection.
The different standards that are required
for the different
bandwidths for our ports.
So you've got all that information.
So surely now, you just plug in, yeah?
No, that's not quite how it goes.
Because in reality, you
personally, as a customer,
probably do not have access
to that meet-me room.
So in reality, you're gonna have to work
with the co-location provider now
to arrange for something
called a cross-connect
between that port that we've allocated
and your infrastructure.
So when we think about getting connected,
unfortunately, there have to
be multiple people involved
in making this connection.
It's not something that you
can own totally yourself.
There's always gonna be at
least three parties involved.
There's obviously AWS on one side,
providing the Direct Connect port.
There's your side of
things, your infrastructure.
And in the middle, we've got
this co-location provider
that needs to make the cross-connect.
The reality also is,
though, if you're connecting
to a facility that is outside
of that particular co-location facility,
then you're probably gonna have to work
with some sort of telco partner, carrier,
maybe even a separate last-mile provider.
And unfortunately, all
of the people involved
probably have their own processes,
their own ways of doing testing.
And I'll come onto this later on,
perhaps their own polarity on their ports
causes some interesting challenges.
So I've been doing this
for quite a few years.
I've worked on a bunch
of customer projects
and internal projects
involving Direct Connect,
and I thought I'd just
share a couple of tips
from my experiences.
And the first one is, I would say,
always draw out a really simple diagram
of what you're trying to
achieve with Direct Connect.
Put AWS on one side, put your
infrastructure on the other,
and then work out all of the
pieces involved in the middle.
Doesn't have to be fancy,
just a very simple diagram
that shows all the locations,
perhaps all the devices
that you're aware of
that these connections
are gonna go through.
On that diagram, identify
who owns each component,
because they will all
have different owners.
And then every port ID,
every circuit number,
everything you see written in an email
or said to you over the phone,
just add it onto that diagram.
And this will become your reference
for everything to do with that
particular Direct Connect.
I also find it quite useful
just to note on there
things like support details,
contact details for the people involved,
because this, as I say,
just becomes your
reference going forwards.
So how do we put all the
pieces together here?
So what I wanted to start
with was the example
where you've got infrastructure
in your own facility,
perhaps your own data center.
It's not within the
Direct Connect location,
so in my example earlier,
the Equinix TY2 facility.
And we want to establish this connection
from an AWS Direct Connect port
all the way through to your equipment.
Now it'd be really nice if you
could just fire off an email
that says, "Hey, partner, could
you just make this happen?
"Here's the LOA from
AWS, here's my equipment.
"Could you just connect the two together?"
I'm not gonna lie, there are some cases
where you can do that.
There are some excellent partners
who have all of the ability
to deliver this end-to-end.
But unfortunately, the reality is
there are usually many
more components involved.
But let's stick with
the example for a moment
where we've asked a partner to deliver it,
and in which case, they simply build
all these connections.
So perhaps they arrange the last mile
from your data center
to a point of presence
in your city for their infrastructure.
Maybe then they configure
across the backbone
that they have over their
optical network into a location,
and they arrange it all, fantastic.
They plug it in, ports come
up on your router, happy days.
As I say, the reality is
a little bit different.
Now, the infrastructure I mentioned there
is in place typically, so there will be
points of presence in your city.
There will be infrastructure in
these co-location facilities
from the various telcos and carriers.
Also, there is the meet-me
room infrastructure
that I mentioned a moment ago.
AWS's equipment is already pre-cabled
from our devices directly
into that meet-me room,
into what you saw in the photo earlier on.
And the chances are
that the large carriers
and telcos in these facilities
are also pre-cabled to the meet-me room.
So what that means is we
still have a few gaps,
but it's not quite as bad
as I showed a moment ago.
But to make all these connections happen,
you can imagine there's gonna be
a lot of communication going on.
There's gonna be the
request from the owner
of the telecoms equipment to request
the cross-connect in the first place.
There's gonna be provisioning of ports
and circuits across the infrastructure.
There's probably gonna be some ordering
of running fiber across a town.
There might even be
involvement of logistics
to dig up the road to run fiber.
All sorts of things could be involved.
But when it comes down to it,
if you break down that simple diagram
and do it in stages, the first piece
is that cross-connect in the meet-me room.
So in this case, the telco has had to ask
Equinix in our example to
make that cross-connect.
The telco has then had to
make physical connections
between patch panels in their
rack and their equipment,
configure circuits over their network,
deliver it to your local city,
perhaps dig up some streets,
and then deliver it into your location
presented on a port ready
to go into your router.
And at that point, we
might have a connection.
The other variation on
this is if you are located
inside that co-location facility already.
Now if you're in there, things
are clearly a lot simpler.
You don't have any of that
external telecoms work to do.
So you'll have your rack, your equipment.
Chances are you're also
pre-cabled to the meet-me room.
If you're not familiar
with that experience,
typically the first time you order
any sort of cross-connect
in many of these facilities,
they will install a whole set of fiber
between your rack and the meet-me room.
And what that means is you
can now interact directly
with that location provider.
So it really is as simple
as then sending the email
that says, "Please can you
make this cross-connect?"
And of course, it might not be an email.
Different providers use portals.
You might upload the details,
provide the document we
give you as evidence.
But effectively, you just
order that cross-connect
and it's done.
I've said cross-connect a couple of times.
A cross-connect really
is just a piece of fiber
being plugged into one port on one side
and another port on the other.
There's nothing more to it.
I regularly get asked, "What
is this cross-connect thing?"
And it's very simple.
It's just a piece of fiber.
So at that point, our connection comes up
and hopefully the thing
you see in the AWS console
is that your port goes from being down
to now showing as available.
The link comes up on your router.
We're in a good place.
But let's just go and verify
that everything is as we expect.
So we have CloudWatch
monitoring for Direct Connect.
There's a whole bunch of the metrics
that you would expect to see there,
bandwidth usage, et cetera.
But I wanted to just draw your attention
to the connection state,
which is a very simple
metric you can look at
that indicates, is the
connection up or down?
If it's one, it's up.
Anything else, it's down.
The other interesting ones to look at here
are the light levels, particularly the RX,
so the receive light level.
And you can see on there,
I've made a note of the ranges
that are considered good.
Effectively, if you
get down to neg 12 DBM,
you're okay, but you could be better.
Start getting beyond that,
this connection probably isn't coming up.
And the reason I'm mentioning this
is you can have a situation where
everything is plugged in and connected,
but you haven't got a link yet.
And it's good to come and
have a look in the console
and actually see what the light level is
because it may well all be
connected absolutely fine,
but you might have some
dirty fiber somewhere
that wasn't cleaned when it was connected
or something like that
that's attenuating the light
that means we've not got
enough signal getting through.
So always go take a look
at the CloudWatch metrics.
Everything I've been talking about so far
is what we refer to as
a dedicated connection.
And it's exactly what it sounds like.
This is a dedicated port
on a piece of AWS equipment
that is assigned to you.
You requested it and
we allocated it to you.
You get full use of that port
and the bandwidth available on it.
It will support multiple
virtual interfaces,
which we're gonna explain a
little bit more in a moment,
but that's effectively
multiple VLANs and BGP sessions
because you're in control of
everything about that port.
Fundamentally, it is physical connectivity
that you're responsible
for to get to the port
that we've allocated to you.
Hosted connections are
a little bit different.
What happens here is
we allocate connections
to one of our Direct Connect partners,
and we actually call them
interconnects at that point.
You may see that term around.
And our partners have
already then taken care
of all that physical connectivity
between their infrastructure and ours.
What they then do is allocate
smaller amounts of bandwidth
on that connectivity to
you and provide it to you
perhaps over an existing fabric or service
they might have with you as a customer.
In that case, our partners can
increase their connectivity
with us by combining connections together.
They can create lags just like you can,
and we'll explain that in a moment.
But they can increase that capacity,
but we don't let partners
oversubscribe those ports.
So as they allocate bandwidth to you,
that bandwidth is passed on to you,
and they have to expand their connectivity
with us over time.
The thing about hosted connection is
you can only have one virtual interface
per hosted connection.
So it's quite common for our customers
to have multiple hosted connections
if they need them for different workloads,
perhaps some for virtual private gateways
and some for transit gateways, et cetera.
I mentioned their lags,
link aggregation groups.
So what a link aggregation group is,
is it allows you to combine
multiple physical connections
into one single thing that is treated
as a dedicated connection.
So you might combine together
four 10 gig connections.
So you have a resulting
40 gig of capacity there,
but you treat it as a single connection
when you're configuring
virtual interfaces,
et cetera, on it.
We'll then do flow hashing of the traffic
across those connections,
and you can configure on the
AWS side and your equipment,
what is the appropriate point
that you would rather shut
down that set of connections
if you lose capacity
versus maintaining it.
So you might have 40 gig of connectivity
and you decide that you really need
to always have 20 gig available.
So if one of those other
connections is impacted,
you're down to 30 gig,
that's fine, keep the lag up.
But if we drop down to 20 gig or below,
perhaps we then shut it down.
And that's configured
as the minimum number
of interfaces on a lag.
So we're in a fairly
good place at this point.
We've assumed everything's
working, but what if it doesn't?
And what I thought I'd do is just talk you
through a couple of situations
that we hear about all the time,
and our support engineers end
up discussing with customers.
So I wanted to just give you
maybe a bit of an insight
into two things that
we hear very regularly.
And that other phrase
is, "Roll the fiber,"
or "I'm gonna put a loop on that."
I see a few people nodding here.
Maybe you've heard that or experienced it.
For those of you that have not worked
with physical fiber equipment,
at the bottom there we've
got what's called an SFP,
a small form factor pluggable module.
And on the right-hand side
we have some duplex fiber
with LC connectors on the end of it.
And the module at the
bottom is what is sitting
in those various pieces
of network equipment
on each end of this connection.
And you might be able to see
in very small writing on there,
it's marked TX and RX.
So that's transmit and receive.
So what happens there on the transmit side
is there is a laser inside that module
that is firing the light out of it.
And when it gets to the other end,
it needs to go into the receive side
of the other connection.
So just to illustrate
that point a little bit,
this would be just two
devices next to each other
with a single duplex fiber cable
that you would just plug in.
This is what would happen.
Transmit would be connected
to receive and vice versa.
We'd all be having a good day.
Packets would be flowing, no problem.
But when you put this
in the context of a code
or location facility, we've
now introduced a meet-me room.
Now, there are no actual standards
for how to do this kind of cabling.
There's some, I guess, best practices
that have been adopted in terms
of where you cross over those pairs.
So typically between your
rack and the meet-me room,
the fiber will have been crossed over.
And if we take that simple
example on the screen there,
you've got two sides of a connection here,
a single meet-me room.
The fibers have been crossed on one side,
crossed on the other.
The patch in the middle
is just a simple fiber
between those ports.
That unravels quite nicely,
and you end up with transmit to receive
and vice versa again.
All good.
The other variation, though,
is when you start adding
in multiple meet-me rooms,
other providers, other
pieces of equipment,
and before you know it,
you've got a situation
where these fibers have
been crossed multiple times.
So when you hear the
phrase roll the fiber,
what they literally mean is swap,
transmit, and receive around.
I've lost track of the number
of times I've visited racks
where I've seen the little clips
on an LC fiber connector broken off
so that the fibers can be swapped around.
It's a very, very common thing.
I wish it was totally
standardized everywhere,
but unfortunately it's not.
So that's what that means if you hear that
when you're debugging a connection.
The other phrase is putting a loop on it.
So what I'm showing you here, very simply,
again, these are just two SFPs,
two devices that are
connected via a meet-me room,
and perhaps the connection
isn't coming up.
And what we wanna do here is identify
where's the potential problem.
Do we have some broken fiber?
What's the issue?
So what will happen here
is you'll hear someone say,
I'm gonna put a loop on that connection
facing towards AWS or
facing towards this carrier.
What that means is in that meet-me room,
they might unplug that fiber,
that cross-connect that we had,
and quite simply, they will
just loop the two together
on one side.
So on the AWS side, our
laser is firing light out.
It gets to that port in the meet-me room.
It gets turned right back
around, sent back to AWS.
And now, in those CloudWatch metrics,
you would see light level being received.
It's not always true that the connection
would come up as such,
but you can see that
that loop has been made.
And even better, you
could see the transition
where there was no loop
at all, no light flowing.
You loop it, it's good.
So now you know the path from AWS
to the meet-me room is good.
The same could be done on the
other side with the carrier,
and it could be done at various places
all the way down the path
to troubleshoot a problem like this.
So they're the two phrases
you're likely to hear.
I thought I would share it with you,
because as I say, our support organization
work with customers
regularly on these things.
And quite often, we find customers
don't necessarily understand
these concepts, which I get.
So hopefully, this clarifies that process.
The last thing I wanted to talk about
in terms of physical
connectivity is MACSEC.
So MACSEC is enabled at the port level,
as I mentioned earlier.
When you request your port,
you check that box at the bottom,
and if it's available for that
bandwidth at that location,
it's now available for you to consume.
MACSEC encrypts the traffic
between two Layer 2 devices.
So if you've got a piece of equipment
in that co-location facility,
and you connect them together
via the cross-connects,
no problem.
If you're connecting outside that facility
to perhaps your data center,
as long as your carrier is passing
through all the Layer 2 traffic,
then you can establish a MACSEC connection
between those two devices.
Once that traffic gets into AWS,
we encrypt all of the traffic
between AWS-secured facilities.
So that MACSEC session
is between your device
and the Direct Connect
device in that location.
The keys for this session
are generated by you.
They're stored inside KMS,
sorry, in Secrets Manager,
and you can then rotate these
if you need to over time.
You have a choice when you
configure MACSEC as well
in terms of what you want
to do with the encryption.
So you can choose no encryption,
maybe that's your starting point.
If this was part of a plan
that you were gonna
enable MACSEC later on,
you'd set it to no encrypt.
There's also then should encrypt,
where the two devices
will try and establish
an encrypted connection between them,
your device to ours, but if it fails,
the connection will still come up.
So that's quite a common stage to go to
as you're rolling out MACSEC connectivity.
You enable it, you set
it to should connect.
That now effectively lets you test it
because if you get it right,
the connection will come up
and you'll see it encrypted.
If it doesn't work, you haven't
interrupted the connection.
And then the final one is must encrypt,
which is exactly what it sounds like.
If we can't establish the encryption
between the two devices
the connection will stay down
and all your virtual interfaces
will be down as well.
So talking of virtual interfaces,
I'm gonna hand over to Josh
to talk about those with you.
- All right, thank you, Steve.
Yeah, so just taking a look at
the virtual interfaces here,
just really quick, just to level set,
Steve kind of alluded to
it, but virtual interface,
that's the VLAN and the BGP, right?
I know you kind of like talk
down about BGP, but I like it.
So we have three main types
and I'm gonna go into
some details on them.
So don't panic.
Public, private and transit.
So public is for connecting
to public AWS endpoints,
S3, that sort of thing.
Private for getting to VPCs.
Transit for getting to transit
gateways and cloud ones
and then to VPCs.
And then we also have the concept
of a hosted virtual interface,
not to be confused with
the hosted connection.
This is a virtual interface owned
by another account's connection.
They configure all the
BGP and all of that stuff
and then you attach it
to your VPC, essentially.
So sometimes that's like
an infrastructure account
or something like that.
(inhales)
So we'll start with
public virtual interfaces.
I'm not gonna go into
super detail on these
'cause I'm kind of hoping you know
at least some level of
understanding about these,
but public virtual interface,
these are, as I said,
connects you to any region.
These are, you use public IPs for peering.
We have some ability to scope these down.
I'll explain that a little later on.
But essentially what it is is
your own personal connection
to the public side of AWS.
To talk about private virtual interfaces,
we have to kind of go back in time first.
We have to go before 2017,
which feels like the way back machine.
Back then, Direct Connect was
kind of a regional service.
So what you had was your
Direct Connect was in a region
and you could connect to your VPCs
that were in that region.
So in my example here, I have US East 1
and I have my VPC in US East 1
and my connection is in US East 1.
I can still connect to multiple VPCs,
but one VPC per virtual interface.
And this is where that concept
of an associated region comes in,
which you may have seen if you've
used Direct Connect at all
because you can still
use this architecture.
Then we kind of moved on a little bit
to this architecture using
Direct Connect Gateway.
So these are still private
virtual interfaces,
but what these do, what
Direct Connect Gateway does
is allows you to bring all
your private virtual interfaces
into one Direct Connect Gateway.
Those can be global from anywhere
and you can then attach
your VPCs anywhere as well.
So you can go kind of
from anywhere to anywhere.
I mean, from on-prem
to VPC, VPC to on-prem.
Then we started to get into the sort of
the transit gateway Cloud WAN world.
You've probably come
across those services.
So we introduced transit
virtual interfaces,
those very similar, similar idea.
You connect to regionally,
you can connect to transit gateways,
Cloud WANs in different
regions, add those on.
One thing to note there,
you cannot mix and match there.
You can't add VGWs and TGWs
and you can't add transit
VIFs and private VIFs
to the same ones.
Just something to keep in mind there.
And then just one other thing
I wanted to point out here,
not necessarily a VIF type,
but kind of a setting on a VIF,
private or transit VIF at least,
is something called site link.
This allows you to take your
traffic from one DX location
to another DX location,
ride the AWS backbone.
The nice thing is, and
you can see I created
a lovely little GIF.
You can just click the button
and you'll start seeing the route show
up on the other side.
So you can kind of use
it as needed, right?
You don't even have to
keep it on all the time.
So taking a quick look at monitoring,
these are sort of building on the things
that Steve talked about before,
but for virtual interfaces,
we also have the bits per
second, ingress, egress,
and packets per second,
so just give you the idea
of what traffic is going
over those connections.
And then we also have an
offering under CloudWatch
called CloudWatch Network
Synthetic Monitor.
That's actually sending real traffic.
So you configure an
endpoint in your subnets
and you configure, you
give us an endpoint on-prem
and we send ICMP or TCP
traffic, you choose,
and we return roundtrip time and
packet loss metrics to you.
There's also a network
health indicator metric
that comes back.
What that is,
it's us looking at all
of our internal metrics
for everything from the subnet all the way
to the direct connect endpoint
that you're connected to,
just to give you kind of a quick look
if you're having a network issue to say,
oh, that's definitely an AWS problem,
I can go yell at them,
or I need to go investigate my network.
And so to troubleshooting
virtual interfaces,
so again, layer one, you should be fine
'cause you've been through
Steve's presentation,
but again, that's kind of the first thing.
If your layer one's not up,
you're not gonna get any further, right?
The next thing to check if
your VIF's not coming up
is layer two, so making
sure your VLAN tags
match on both sides.
The other thing we see pretty commonly,
especially when you start adding
in partners and providers,
they love to use these
encapsulation technologies.
Again, totally fine, no problem,
but we need to make sure
once they are facing,
like the port facing AWS,
those are stripped off
and it's just the VLAN of
your virtual interface.
Then once you get up another layer,
you're into sort of BGP layer
three sort of issues, right?
So you can kind of see it
goes two different ways.
If you're seeing in your BGP logs,
stuff getting stuck in
idle, connect active,
it's probably a network
connectivity problem.
If you're getting over that,
you're getting into
open sent, open confirm,
it's a BGP parameter
problem more than likely.
Okay, so I wanna talk a
little bit about routing
because there's a lot to it.
First thing I wanted to bring up here,
just kind of as I'm thinking about it,
as I was thinking about this,
there are the limits and some limits
are more important than others
and they kind of come
in at different places.
So on the screen,
I've got virtual interfaces per connection
and transit virtual
interfaces per connection.
Those are super important,
but those only really matter
when you're architecting
your network, right?
The next two routes per peer,
those can take down your network
or take down your direct connect
if you exceed them at any point.
So you really wanna kind of make sure
you have a good
understanding of your routes
and are summarizing and making sure
you're kind of keeping
those under control.
So I'll give you some ideas
on how you can do that.
First of all, here's an example
of like a route filtering.
So here I'm filtering
just for a couple of /24s,
applying those as a route map to my peer,
sending just those routes to AWS.
Another option here is
using summarization.
So I'm using this
aggregate address command.
So basically what it's
saying is I've got those 24s,
ignore those, send a
/16, only the summary.
And then at the bottom,
I'm injecting a default route
using default originate.
The idea there being just
send a default route to AWS
and then use the VPC route
tables, TGW route tables,
that sort of thing to control
exactly which traffic you're sending.
Okay, how do you configure the routing?
Active, passive, passive,
no, active, active,
that sort of thing, right?
That's kind of the next step.
This is the mnemonic
device I was always taught.
So I hope some of you have used that too.
Still don't understand
why there's two oranges.
I find that super confusing,
but I've never used origin or origin type
to decide a route, so it's fine.
Okay, so here's an example.
I've got an Ashburn, Virginia,
direct connect to New York direct connect.
My VPC is in US East 1, my
data center's in Virginia.
I wanna prefer the Ashburn direct connect.
So how can I do that?
Well, one way is AS
path per pending, right?
That's pretty common in the industry,
very common way to do it.
The other way that we could do it with AWS
is using local preference communities.
So we have this set of communities
that allow you to influence AWS's
local preference, essentially.
Then obviously you wanna also
apply the same metric locally
onto the routes you're receiving from us
just to kind of keep things symmetric.
And just so you can kind of see
what those routes would look like,
the top two routes are
the preferred routes,
the shorter AS path,
and the higher local preference community.
All right, what if you
bought all this bandwidth
and you wanna use it all?
Why not?
You wanna go active active.
I've got two connections now
in that same data center.
How can I utilize everything?
Well, I could just use
the same local preference
communities on both.
Technically could also
use the same AS path.
I personally like to use the
local preference communities
because I feel like it,
since it's higher up the list
of like the decision tree,
it makes me feel a
little more comfortable.
But you could also do this
with AS path per pending.
But local preference is my choice.
But this way we'll ECMP
traffic across both.
So obviously advise you would
do the same on your side,
but that way we're splitting traffic
across both connections.
So for resiliency purposes,
maybe now I'm going back
to my two data center
or I'm adding a second data center.
Now I have a data center in New York,
but my data center is still in Virginia.
I probably don't wanna
ECMP across everything
because I'm gonna have
some weird latency problems
and things are gonna start
arriving out of order
and that sort of thing, right?
So in that case, generally,
I'm gonna apply my local
preference communities
on the closest.
So that would be, well, I would pick one,
but I would pick my aspirin
since that's the closest
and then kind of a lower priority
on the New York data center.
Then obviously if things fail,
we can ECMP on the other
one, everything's fine.
Now, I've never really
come across a network
that's that super clean.
They're usually a little
messier than that.
And obviously we only have three
local preference communities.
So what do you do if you
have four routes or more
or four different paths
and you wanna go one,
two, three, four in order?
Well, for that sort of use case,
what I would do, what I recommend,
just equal out the local
preferences everywhere
and then use AS-Passive.
So you can kind of get,
you can get super granular.
You could go more than
four obviously with this.
But that's how I would handle it.
Okay, just on public VIFs for a minute.
I kind of mentioned
these a little bit ago.
The scoping communities that we have,
these allow you to filter
the routes from AWS
that you receive, the public routes,
and only accept routes for
either the local region,
the local continent, or
accept everything globally.
Likewise, you can tell AWS,
I only want you to advertise my route
into the local region,
the local continent,
or you can do it globally.
The other thing to note,
if you advertise the
same route with an ISP
and over Direct Connect,
we're gonna prefer Direct Connect
unless you advertise
something more specific
or something like that.
We don't apply local
preference communities here.
Those don't apply.
You can use the AS-Path for Pending
as long as you are using a public ASN.
So if you use a private ASN,
you're just gonna strip it off
and use a public one internally.
And then ECMP, it gets
a little bit sketchier
with public VIFs to be honest.
And I would generally just
say within the same location,
you can do ECMP as long as
everything else is the same.
And so just a couple things.
To take a look at,
these are what the routes
look like coming from AWS.
First of all, you'll notice
that we apply an ASN.
We do a bit of prepending
and we apply the no export.
That's really just to protect us from,
if you were to leak the routes
out to an ISP or something,
obviously your ISP should stop you.
But just in case they didn't,
we've got a little bit of protection.
I've seen customers
strip off the no export,
advertise them internally,
that sort of thing.
That's totally fine.
It's just kind of a little
accidental protection.
And then you'll see at the
bottom there, the 8100,
that's just saying that
this route originated
from that region,
from the region that my
direct connect is in.
Okay.
So, a bit of failover testing, right?
Super important, once
you get your setup going,
you're gonna have maintenance,
things are gonna happen.
Somewhere along that big,
long, complicated chain
of partners and providers,
something's gonna go down.
So, you wanna know that you're good.
So, you can do that any number of ways.
We do have a little failover testing tool,
which lets you bring down BGP.
You can set a time for
that, up to 72 hours,
which seems like a lot,
but you could set it to
be down for 72 hours.
If it all goes wrong,
thankfully you can cancel it.
That's good.
And then just a note on our SLA as well,
that we have for direct connect.
So, we have three models for our SLA.
First one is a single
connection deployment,
pretty much is what it says.
You have one connection.
The next one is a
high-resilient, multi-site,
non-redundant connection.
It's a mouthful, but what
it means, essentially,
is that you're at two locations,
but you only have a single
connection at those locations.
And then finally, we have
the maximum resiliency,
multi-site redundant deployment,
which is at least four connections,
two at each site, and on
two different devices,
two different AWS devices.
So, those are for your maximum,
can't-have-downtime, super workloads.
And then just expanding on,
so Steve mentioned
MACSec a little bit ago.
There's another option that we see
with encryption over direct connect,
and that's using IPsec.
In that case, direct connect becomes
kind of like the transport underneath,
and then you apply your
IPsec tunnel over the top,
from VGW to your own firewall or router.
You can do this with
public or private IPs.
It used to be kind of problematic
because you'd be limited
to the tunnel size
of like 1.25 gigs per tunnel.
They recently upped that
to five gigs per tunnel,
so that actually really helps.
So, this becomes a bit
more of a viable option.
Okay.
On the subject of performance,
just keep in mind as well,
you can send as much bandwidth
as your EC2 instance can handle.
That's totally fine.
But keep in mind, if you're
doing benchmark testing
or something like that,
that a single flow,
like if you do an IPerf
or something like that,
a single flow, you can only get five gigs.
So, make sure you're
spreading it out a little bit.
And then just make sure you make the most
of your connections.
So, if you can support jumbo frames
on private and transit VIFs, do that.
Because you'll get the most out of it.
Public VIFs, we only support 1500,
but you still get the idea.
And a pretty good blog post there.
If you take a look at that, some good tips
on how to improve your performance,
make sure you're doing good.
Okay, Steve.
- Brilliant.
Okay, so we've got our
connection up and running.
We probably wanna understand how much
this is going to cost.
And this is a question that
comes up quite regularly
in customer discussions that I have.
So, what I thought I would
do is just put together
a couple of examples so you
can consider the components
that are involved when you're working at
how much does Direct Connect cost you.
So, in our example, we're gonna have
a very simple setup to start with.
So, we have our EC2
instance running in a VPC.
In this example, it's in US West 2.
We have a Direct Connect location,
which I've chosen for it to be in London.
And I have my customer
location on-premises.
This is how they're connected together.
Obviously, this is a non-redundant setup,
thinking back to what Josh
was telling you about.
So, what do we need to consider?
When you're looking at pricing of anything
to do with data transfer inside AWS,
you need to consider
it in both directions.
So, in the first instance,
we're gonna consider
data transfer between AWS going
towards a customer network.
What are the costs that
we need to consider
in this particular scenario?
Well, perhaps the most obvious one
is the Direct Connect port itself.
So, there is a charge for
the Direct Connect port.
It's charged per hour, and it's charged
from when the connection
comes up for the first time,
or 90 days have elapsed from the point
that you ordered the connection.
We recognize that when you click order,
it's very unlikely that
you're gonna be able
to plug in immediately
and benefit from that.
There's gonna be time involved
to arrange all those
cross-connects, those circuits,
everything I talked about earlier on.
But once that connection
comes up and is stable,
we'll start billing at an
hourly rate for that port.
And you'll get that charge now
until you completely delete that port.
So, that's an important thing to remember,
and it's consistent through
each of the architectures
I'm gonna show you.
The next piece is the data transfer itself
from the EC2 instance,
leaving AWS going towards
your infrastructure.
And when you look at our pricing pages,
that's where you see the wording
data transfer from AWS
region or local zone.
And it's charged per gigabyte transferred.
The way this works is you go
and look at the pricing table,
you identify where is
the traffic coming from.
So, in this case, from the
continuous US, for example,
and it's going to Europe.
You can then work out how
much that's going to cost you
per gigabyte transferred.
So, the table for that is
on the Direct Connect pricing page.
In fact, that's where you
can find all of the answers
for these examples.
So, this is, as I say, a simple setup
with Direct Connect gateway
and a virtual private gateway.
What about data transfer into
AWS in this architecture?
Well, in this case,
we still have the Direct Connect port fee.
Obviously, it's not being
charged twice in this situation,
but that's still a constant.
But for data transfer
in, in this situation,
where we're going via a
virtual private gateway,
we don't charge you for
any data transfer inbound
in this scenario.
Let's look at a variation of that.
What about with Transit Gateway?
So, we still got our
Direct Connect gateway.
We've now got, though, the
Transit Gateway on that path,
and perhaps you've got
many hundreds or thousands
of VPCs connected to that Transit Gateway.
So, once again, let's look at it
from the perspective of data transfer
out from AWS to your infrastructure.
We have good old port hour charge there.
That's still the same.
We also have the data transfer charge.
That's still the same as well.
No difference there.
We're moving data across
the AWS infrastructure.
But the addition of the Transit Gateway
does mean that we now have to consider
a per hour attachment charge,
and we've got two attachments,
one towards Direct Connect,
one towards the VPC,
and then we have a data processing charge
for the Transit Gateway.
So, in this scenario,
they're the components
you would add together to calculate
how much this particular
workload would be costing you.
Let's look at it from
the other perspective,
data transfer into AWS
with this architecture.
Still got the same components,
Transit Gateway sitting there.
So, our old friend, the port
hour charge, still there.
Data transfer coming into AWS,
there's no charge for that,
but we do still have the
Transit Gateway on that path.
So, what that means is we still
have the attachment charge,
and again, this is not
being charged twice.
It's the same attachments we
talked about a moment ago,
and there is the data processing charge
for the traffic that is moving
through that Transit Gateway.
So, I mention both of these scenarios
because you could have a scenario
where it's useful to use
the Virtual Private Gateway architecture
for certain workloads,
and perhaps the Transit Gateway
or Cloud WAN-based
architecture for another.
Josh mentioned SiteLink,
so I wanted to just cover off
how we bill for that as well.
In this situation, I've added
another Direct Connect location in.
It's here in Las Vegas,
and therefore I now have expanded
to have a US office for this organization.
The EC2 infrastructure's still there.
I've grayed it out because
the billing for that
is exactly what I've been
talking about so far.
But for SiteLink,
there's a couple of
other things to consider.
When you create the virtual interfaces
that you're going to use for SiteLink,
you're gonna attach those
to a Direct Connect gateway.
We've still got the port hour charges.
They're still there.
We create the virtual interfaces,
and we check that box
that Josh showed you.
At that point, we've now enabled SiteLink,
and there is a charge for
enabling that capability
on each of those virtual interfaces.
Once you've done that,
the traffic is now able to flow
between my UK office location
and my US office location,
going through the Direct
Connect infrastructure.
And to work out how much that costs,
you need to now go and look up on a table
that we have on the
Direct Connect website.
So for traffic flowing
from the UK to the US,
you would go and look up in the table
and identify this traffic is
coming from Europe to the US,
and then vice versa,
traffic the other way,
you'd go and look up the
table in the other direction.
And as you can see in this example,
it's actually the same charge here,
but that's how you calculate
the pricing involved for SiteLink.
Okay, now there's a few
components involved in there,
and I wanted to share something
that we published a few months back,
which was the open source
networking focused calculator.
We have the AWS pricing calculator,
I'm sure you've all seen that.
But we actually have this
tool that we put out there
for you to be able to
deploy and use yourselves
to help calculate anything
to do with networking on AWS.
It pulls from our pricing APIs.
And I just wanted to mention it,
there's a blog post all about it.
So if you're trying to calculate
how much these architectures
cost in advance,
you may want to deploy the
pricing calculator tool
that we've published there.
- So you may have seen
over the last few days,
we announced this new capability
called AWS Interconnect Multicloud
in partnership with Google and Preview.
I just wanted to spend
a quick second on it.
I think it's super cool, personally.
What it does is allows you
to kind of create capacity
to another cloud, to GCP in this case.
What we're doing is building in
our maximum resiliency model.
So the four-wide connectivity
that I was talking about before,
it's all pre-cabled, it's all pre-built.
All you have to do is go and say,
I want one gig, I want 50
megs, whatever you want.
And you can get that from us
through this new offering.
So GCP for now, I think Rob Kennedy said
in his innovation talk today,
first half 26 for Azure to
be added to this as well.
And there was a talk earlier today,
so unfortunately you missed that,
but a deep dive onto this,
I think it was NET205.
- Five, it was, yeah.
- So if you wanna go
look that up on YouTube,
probably in the next day
or so, it'll pop up there
if you wanna get more information on that.
All right, and just to wrap up,
some things that we want you
to take away and remember.
So first of all, just going
all your way through the layers
as you configure and troubleshoot,
start layer one and kind
of work your way up.
Using the right VIF for the right job.
A lot of times you can't use the wrong VIF
for the wrong job, but it is
good to kind of consider that.
Getting a good idea of what
you're gonna do with BGP.
Are you gonna need to
do some summarization?
What do you need to do
with the communities?
Like, do you need to
configure active, active,
active, passive, what
are you thinking there?
You wanna design for resilience, right?
So again, as you're building,
are you trying to meet a
particular sort of SLA?
Is this a high available
workload or is it a,
I'm just testing and I don't care.
And then obviously test and test and test
and make sure everything
fails over as it should.
Understand how to calculate your costs.
I think that solution,
the open source solution
is a really great way to do that.
Or you can go watch this on YouTube
and rewind and watch the
last five minutes again.
And then just embracing your capabilities.
So if you're using Direct Connect,
Direct Collider VGWs, try
out Direct Connect Gateway.
It's super easy, doesn't add any cost,
doesn't add any latency,
and really just kind of
expands your portfolio.
Try out Transit Gateways,
try out SiteLink,
try out Cloud WAN, try out InterConnect.
Yeah, thank you very much.